the deputy leader of the SNP Murray
black
[Music]
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I
also wish to send my warm regards to the
family of Paul O'Grady the legendary
drag queen for all he's done for my
community I also want to congratulate
Hamza Yusuf as he becomes
and Muslim to hold such an office I'm
sure the whole house will send his one
regards now in recent days video footage
has emerged of the former Chancellor and
the former chair of the 1922 committee
offering their services
for sixty thousand pounds on top of
their MPS salary the former Health
secretary offered his wisdom for ten
thousand pounds a day going once can I
ask the Deputy Prime Minister when he is
inevitably booted out of office what
will his going rate mean
can I can I welcome her to uh the the
chamber uh the system of the system of
declarations is there to ensure
transparency and accountability and of
course the conservatives backed
tightening up those rules to make sure
that there couldn't be any lobbying but
can I also join with a except to take
her up on her tribute to the first uh
the new first minister of Scotland the
Prime Minister spoke to him last night
we welcome him to his place and of
course the government wants to work
constructively with him in the best
interest of the people of Scotland
during a cost of living crisis as his
colleagues eye up barrels of cash from
fake companies it's the people across
these aisles that have been led by
donkeys
now the former Health secretary also
said that he would impact his wisdom for
1500 pounds an hour most nurses earn
little above 15 pounds an hour who does
the Deputy Prime Minister thinks best
value for money and for the public
[Applause]
I'm delighted that the majority of their
health unions have accepted uh the pay
settlement we we think that that's
absolutely uh we think that's absolutely
right and she she raises the issue uh
and of course we've uh We've uh worked
with on a cross-party basis to curb the
limits on second earnings I I noticed
the benches on this side are curiously
quiet
is that because there's ten Shadow
cabinet members on their benches uh who
are taking earnings in particular the
shadow foreign safety looks like he he
certainly doesn't want to be under the
Limelight
[Applause]
he's got earn second earnings from 40
different sources I I don't think uh
they can talk about it and uh as far as
the honorable lady is concerned we've
done everything we can to make sure
there's transparency and accountability